Mom, we have to go now.
Give me three more minutes.
Go eat something.
I'm going to say yes
to everyone who asks me out
for the next 30 days.
How does that work?
On an app or something,
or walking down the street
and somebody asks me out.
When does that happen?
I don't know
when women flirt.
-Are you a bad boy?
-I'm a bad boy.
I'd assume
you've been flirting with me,
but you'd say what? "No"?
Well, of course
I'm gonna say no.
All right.That's the point.
How about you,
is there anyone?
Yeah. There's a lady.
Her name is Tinder.
She's great.
She has many different faces.
I ended up telling Brian
that we were open.
Really? You told him
just 'cause it came up,
or you told him 'cause
you're hoping
some other stuff
will come up?
Ever heard that phrase,
"The best way
to get over one man
is to get under another"?
Every time I think
I have it figured out,
something like this happens.
I want to try other things
and have more experiences
before I just end up
in a relationship forever.
Hey, I'm proud of you.
-For real?
-Yeah. Let's go.
You are smart, and bright,
and exceptional.
And funny and gorgeous.
Funny and stunning.
I just feel like
you've gotta reach.
God, I'm just filled
with self-help BS.
It's working.
It's like a video game.
It is, but it's fun in that way.
Like, you could win.